we start this newshour with breaking
news from ukraine russian missiles have
hit a crowded shopping mall in the
central ukrainian city of kremen chuk
more than a thousand people are believed
to have been in the center at the time
of the attack charles stratford is
joining us right away from kiev to give
us an update on what you're hearing
about this attack charles
that's right horrific pictures that we
have begun to be uh seeing on twitter
and social media platforms of this
shopping mall reportedly hit by at least
one russian missile this afternoon as
you reported
the president actually has come out now
president zielinski has said that um
over a thousand people are inside or
were inside this mall
at the time this missile hit
um the city is interesting in as far as
what's happened there in the last few
days certainly yesterday
there was a russian attack on a bridge
in the city there was one person
confirmed dead in that strike another
five injured
certainly the ukrainian authorities are
saying that this shopping mall is
nowhere near any kind of strategic
institution or factory anything to do
with weapons
and it is a long way away from front
lines it's around at least 200
kilometers from the southern front line
probably a similar sort of distance from
the eastern front line it sits on the
denepa river
above the city of dunipro
so yeah we are hearing gradually of
reports of casualties as well
according to
a government source at least
two people have been killed so far and
another 20 injured
and of course condemnations are coming
through from government officials as
well um the head of the presidential
office describing it as basically
another russian atrocity russia should
be called to account
for this attack
of course russia has continuously said
that it has no intention of hitting
civilian targets and actively tries to
avoid them it was interesting yesterday
the missile strikes in in the capital
kiev they sunday morning very very early
very few civilians about but of course
there was civilian
infrastructure residential buildings hit
in that attack also so
yeah as i say horrific scenes of of fire
billowing smoke we're beginning to see
pictures also of the injured being
carried out of that mile um
horrific scenes
in that area cro-manchuk or that city
kromanchek which is effectively sort of
central eastern ukraine but as i say a
very long way away from front lines all
right charles we'll check in with you
later on thank you so much ross ratford
reporting for us from kiev